[Music]
all right so before we go to aaron in
sacramento and let everybody know this
is a different
show today um this is a
yeah i'll just leave it at that leave it
this is a different show it's gonna hang
with us it's gonna be um incredible but
um we're gonna take this in a little bit
different direction than we normally go
erin
this is delony how are you man
i'm doing pretty good dr john how are
you
given the circumstances that's that's
pretty incredible man
well i'll have to give you an update at
some point but uh yeah given the
circumstances it's been the worst month
of my life yeah absolutely
so um
for the listener and for you um you oh
this is your story to tell and so um i'd
love to you hop in here whenever uh i
kelly let me know um
last week that you had reached out to us
and had had a
hurricane
and an atomic bomb and everything else
you can imagine go off inside your home
and you reached out wanted to
want to spend some time together and man
we cleared the whole deck and
this show is just gonna be me and you
that's it and um
i can recap what i know or if you feel
comfortable i'd love for you to tell
your story i know you've rehashed this a
million times um
in court in the public and all uh you
know purchasing the pear tree but um if
you're comfortable i'd love for you to
tell your story and give us an update of
where you're at and then how i can help
yeah sure yeah i can i can kind of give
you a the back story just in my own
words um i haven't had to tell it in
court yet thank god but um
yes i was taking back four weeks ago
today um just a regular monday day i was
at work myself with my daughter i'm a
owner operator trucker so i have daddy
daughter day you know i have five kids
by the way um oldest is 17 my youngest
daughter is eight there's three boys in
between
16 13 and 10.
and my oldest boy was at college and so
my mom my mom my wife was home with my
three middle boys
and uh just a regular old monday nothing
was going on my wife was just sitting at
the dining room table in our house and
um
little did we know that my
my older two boys at home 16 and 13 year
old had premeditated um an attack on on
my wife
and uh
carried out just out of nowhere um no
one saw any signs coming no one no one
would expected it
still is baffling four weeks later it
makes no sense
um but they did they they're in their
little minds their plan was to attack
mom and i think escape you know leave
the house take the van because the old
one has a driver's license and and leave
the state and who knows what they were
going to do but that was what was in
their mind
my older son took it upon himself i
don't think this was this was
pre-planned but he went into a murderous
rage and actually tried to kill my wife
um
and very nearly did um and then they
came at her with knives and a baseball
bat my oldest son had a baseball bat
again unprovoked she was stabbed
quite a few times
she was beating over the head with a
baseball bat my ten-year-old who was not
in the same room her mom screamed and
came running to see what was going on i
went running for help
and he got taken down by my older son
with a baseball bat took a really really
bad
head injury
the back of his head
and um
uh it lasted about 45 minutes you know
moved from different rooms a different
room my wife escaped to this and that
and
ended up in
our bedroom and
she ended up talking
getting my 16 year old to talk getting
the talk and getting the talk
and she started praying for everybody
and asked us for more time you know um
she thought her life was you know she
told me that she thought her life was
over
um and she just sort of you know asked
for some time to pray for him and she
started praying and
um
got him to talk and asked you know what
you know what he was planning on doing
and
why he was doing this and he was
murderous he he stayed it out right he
was planning on on murdering her and he
thought he'd already killed my my
ten-year-old son turns out it wasn't
true
but um he got her got him to talk got
him talk and eventually after 45 minutes
or so
he called 911
confessed to what had happened told him
there was my wife was hurt my son was
hurt
and uh they
told him to give the phone to my mom my
wife i keep doing it sorry that's okay
my wife
um
and uh and so 911 was on the phone with
my wife they put the weapons down went
outside and cooperated um deputies came
and they arrested my two sons
and they took my youngest son and my
wife to the emergency room
and
immediately went into surgery
life-threatening injuries both of them
i got wind of something funny going on
because my son actually sent a message
over the internet to a friend i still
don't even know who that is
who called our church who called me and
said hey i got this really funny message
about
you know your son and so i actually
raced home so i was only about a half
hour away and i couldn't get hold of my
wife and i showed up and there was a
dozen
deputies around my house who was closed
and uh they wouldn't tell me what was
going on but i knew it was bad yeah you
know
ask is anyone dead
i figured someone had to be dead for all
that and
thank god that wasn't quite the case but
it was close it was very very close
um
so i don't know where you're going to
skip to from there but that's what
happened um so let's stop there for a
minute okay um
mean i don't have any words man
and you've you've obviously listened to
the show and you know that's a rare
moment
but i've had a word
um
but brother my heart's broken for you
yeah i didn't either i spent the
afternoon in the hospital both my wife
and my younger son were in emergency
surgery at two different hospitals by
the way which made it oh yeah oh
yeah just that i did a complications
down the road but
um i i just i was pacing around the
hospital not knowing
al all i knew in the moment was
my son was completely not responsive his
peoples were dilated he had no response
whatsoever but they took him into
surgery and they you know he had
traumatic brain injury sure
and um
but i knew my wife
going into surgery was
repeating my name and my phone number
over and over and over trying to get
them to call me so that i knew what was
going on and
i
i was hopeful that she
i knew she wasn't dead yeah um but i um
when i got
when i got a debrief from the doctor
after like five hours of pacing the
hospital from about my son uh they
without using the words they basically
told me he was not going to survive yeah
and they they lowered expectations they
said it's not good it's not good yeah um
they have some sort of scale they use
when they bring him to the hospital like
a 1 to 15 for brain injuries right he
was a 1 he was a 1. wow
they they had no hope that this kid
would survive
and so
first i mean
lord willing none of us are ever in this
situation
um
give give people a a
some words about the disassociative
effects of you're just walking i mean
the lights are brighter and things feel
like you're in a video game or you're
not real walk people through just pacing
the hospital um all the text messages
start coming through this is in the
media this is all over the place
it wasn't it wasn't that first day uh
first night you know not in the first
hours anyway you know that took a little
while okay
um you know in the first in the hospital
i'm pacing the hospital i got a hold of
my son that was in the college and the
the sheriff's uh
they had a pr person on site by the time
i got there he actually is in civilian
clothes he actually drove me to the
hospital and my daughter who's with me
that's great
and then he went and picked up my son so
the three of us
were at least together in the hospital
but
i had no idea what was going on i had no
idea what to tell my kids and
i felt like i should be sitting there
broken down crying but i wasn't i was
just kind of
i don't know which is one of my kind of
questions for you long-term i still feel
kind of just numb up
weird yeah we'll get to those questions
so yeah
but in the moment it's just completely
numbing and it's just you know you don't
you don't plan for something like that
obviously no one does this is something
you read about on a you know in the news
or something and all of a sudden you're
in it
oh man
so
three or four weeks have gone by now
walk us through what the last three or
four weeks have been like
maybe the best three or four weeks of my
life
um
i mean i'll skip right to the end my
wife is out of the hospital we um wow
i didn't hadn't heard that man oh yeah
and my my son i'm in the hospital with
him right now i'm not with him i'm in
the next room over but
um
he's going to be discharged in the next
couple of days john is stop dude
yes it is absolutely a miracle no one
can really fathom
what has happened to
like i said i had faith my my wife would
make it out of this in some fashion but
i thought four weeks ago that i was
going to lose my son
and four weeks later they're literally
talking about discharging tomorrow or
not tomorrow wednesday what's his
cognitive capacity
amazing for where he is
he's walking he's talking he's eating i
mean they took the feeding tube out last
sun this last week because he spent the
whole week eating everything they would
put in front of his face he's got the
appetite of an amazing 10 year old
little boy 10 year old yeah
yeah
and i have a snack
can i have a snack yeah
i mean so you know the last four weeks
for four weeks or sorry for a week he
spent completely sedated he was in the
the picu the pediatric icu
at the children's hospital here and
completely sedated he had monitors
everywhere breathing tube feeding tube
the whole nine yards they were you know
uh drains out of his head for excess
blood just that whole thing you know
and after the first couple of days when
it was apparent he wasn't going to die
which that's what we all thought i mean
you know the nurses everything but after
a couple days the swelling wasn't
getting much worse and
it was looking like okay this is gonna
be okay but
even at that point then there's you know
you
have no idea what this kid's life is
gonna be like you don't know if he's
gonna come back at all he might be brain
dead even if he comes back we were
getting warnings over and over from
nurses about how
um i don't remember the terminology but
they had terms for
different kind of outbursts that they
would have or different personalities
that they would come back with sometimes
and
you know they were telling us this kid's
not gonna be the same kid even if he
makes a recovery and they're looking at
six to nine months in the icu
and all of this stuff and so we spent
about a week there
and after a week they they
his body was good enough that they could
take the sedation completely down and
then he started to kind of wake up and
after a couple days he could kind of
communicate a little with his hands you
know he could give a thumbs up or he'd
get you know one finger for one two
finger no or so i wouldn't figure if he
has two finger for no kind of thing
and so we could communicate just little
bits like that and then you know week
and a half later i mean he was getting
better and better and every day the
doctors were just amazed they finally
took him out of the icu and moved into a
regular hospital room because there
wasn't any need for that
level you know took him the breathing
tube out after a week and a half or so
and he was in the regular hospital room
and oh i got to add in just the whole
this whole coveting nonsense i mean i'm
in california dude it's crazy out here
so
and so they only let two people on the
visitor list total you can't change it
around it's not two at a time it's two
people total
and so it's been basically myself and my
mom his grandma are like the only two
people that have been able to see him
this entire time which is just crazy
yeah and adds the whole emotional toll
of it all absolutely
but
um he was in that hotel room and i can't
tell you the excitement one morning i
was
my mom was up visiting with him in the
morning and i was gonna come and leave
her at some point and i got a text from
her saying uh when are you gonna be here
uh your son wants to know i thought that
was kind of a weird thing to say because
i was you know i definitely was
communicating ones and twos yeah and
this is like a week and a half ago i
came around the corner into his room and
he looked me dead in the eye and said hi
dad that was the first words i heard of
his mouth
man hey i'm smiling ear to ear too aaron
i can hear you smiling on the phone now
that's amazing man it's been an amazing
recovery and
um
you know that's all good i mean there's
all the other stuff we're going to deal
with i guess in court and all that
it's just been amazing and like i said
we're out of the hospital a couple days
he's walking talking he's got to wear a
helmet because he's got a piece of his
skull still missing sure
um outside of that he he looks like he
talks a little slower than he used to
and he's got to think a little harder
but outside that he's the same kid that
i knew in love four and a half weeks ago
absolutely man and some of that some of
that speech is
can be anesthetic related even and so
once you get him out and get him into
his own environment that um that's dude
that is incredible man thank you for
sharing that you just made my whole day
yeah absolutely so the other side of
that is is you've got two kids who are
in the court system for
at some level of attempted murder and
they were arraigned they were arraigned
several weeks ago with both of them two
counts of attempted murder okay is
anybody being tried as an adult
uh my older son the state has declared
they are going to attempt to wow 16
yep jeez man
and so walk me through
the feelings you have on the other side
of this so you've you've got the
trauma of
i just may have lost my best friend and
partner and wife
and i may have lost my 10 year old baby
son
yep and
oh my gosh incredible they're safe and
now you've got this other side of this
conversation which is
yep
i've got two
two kids that tried to murder my my
family
yep so walk me through what's in your
heart mind there
it makes everything weird
they've appointed special lawyers that
are not um
the public defenders because of the
circumstances with you know i and my
wife are victims and parents at the same
time that makes the whole legal system
weird when i'm talking to detectives
sometimes they're talking to me as the
parent and sometimes they're talking to
me as the you know
father of the accused as a victim yeah
yeah yeah and
and so you gotta you gotta
walk that line but um i mean long story
short they like i said they both got
arraigned in court
there's definitely a
an aggressor and a follower situation
going on between the two of them but in
the eyes of the law they both
participated in some fashion yeah
and so they're both guilty of of
attempted murder and i mean thank god
for them it's it's as little as that you
know given how how brutal it was good
man
i've i've met with uh
both of myself i'm the only one that's
gotten in front of them other than
lawyers
and other counselors
that are in the juvie system
and that's tough i mean you sit in front
of them and tell me about your
conversation with your 16 year old
that one is difficult i've only got in
front of them once i was gonna get in
front of them here in a couple of days
again but
they wouldn't let me see them for a
couple of weeks given the weirdness of
the situation but they finally did a
couple weeks ago and um
he was very
um reserved
i don't i've been thinking about how to
put this
because
i don't know the the psychological
mental illness world but i i do think in
conversations with a couple people that
have met with him in the juvenile system
there may be a burdening
mental illness of some kind going on
with him we don't know obviously hasn't
been diagnosed and i don't want to put
anything in his mind that's not there
sure but in in speaking with him in
person
i mean he did meet with me he didn't
refuse um but he was very reserved very
down he said he regretted what had
happened
but he
he was so it looked like depression i
mean it looked like a kid that was
depressed and understandably so sure at
this point
his life as he knew it was over yeah
yeah yeah and he had so much going for
him but
he
just the look in his face you know just
showed
the depression
yeah
yeah and out in hearing my wife tell the
story of that day i don't know if it was
some sort of i mean i've heard the term
manika pack i don't know if there's any
media going on in that moment but it was
such a high and low between the when
that thing started and when it ended
that day
and then i'm looking at him now and he's
he's not that kid that could do
something like that you know
he just looks depressed and down he says
he regrets it he's not
sure what to do obviously he's a 16 year
old kid he's a kid yeah yeah and i don't
know what to do with him either i'm not
i've never had to deal with courts and
judges and all this stuff yeah
not my world
well dude um as we get into what we do
next
thank number one thanks for telling your
story and for unpacking that i know
that's a
horrible story we could probably spend
another few days together talking about
your other two kids you got a younger
daughter who was with you just lost
everything and you've got an older child
who's in college just lost everything
and
um
here you are dad at the epicenter here
having to hold all this stuff together
the two kids who are in the court system
now who you so badly want to love and
believe in and who also tried to murder
your wife
and you've got your
recovering
two traumatic brain injuries in your
home one of which is
the other
i would say half but let's be real um
you're a truck driver so she's the other
85 of you know the person who runs the
house
and
then you got two other little kids who
if they had friends that this had gone
through you'd be there for them because
it'd be traumatic and it's in their own
house and so
here you are in the middle
holding a
unspooled sweater just a pile of string
man that's what i feel like i feel like
i am in the middle of everything i'm the
dad i'm the husband i'm the father i'm
the you are one of the grandparents are
there i'm the you know i'm the point of
contact for the police for the lawyers
for everything you are man so
let's take some time dude um
you're still in this you said it best
you haven't you haven't just fallen
apart you haven't cried and there's that
weird meta moment that starts happening
thinking huh
i would have thought if my kids were
incarcerated or i would have thought if
my wife was almost gonna was was almost
about to leave us that i would act this
way but my body's acting that way right
so you have this almost right
meta disassociative you start talking to
yourself in the voice behind the voice
right like what's actually happening
right
and then there's those weird nights you
just go home and
like i'm just gonna turn on the office
and it's this like you're here but
you're not here right
so dude any questions you want to ask
i'll go there with you
okay
i don't
i don't know it is that weird feeling of
being in the middle you you know i don't
i don't watch the office but i sit
around playing stupid video poker for
hours in the evening just whittling away
time when i when i have my own time you
know
yeah that's my that's my my numbing
agent i guess it's just just killing
random times staying up way too late and
i'm i don't sleep because you know
everyone yells at me about getting
enough sleep and eating and
easier said than done oh yes yes yes so
for whatever it's worth you get a pass
for a few days okay cool good okay
you get a pass all right so man let's
let's do this any tell me what's on your
heart and mind and how i can how i can
help
again i don't even know john i
i guess i guess
i need i need a little help on just all
these different all these different
pieces i got my wife that i can't really
even share everything with you know
with the family i i can't really talk to
her about my older sons you know yeah
it's like but i can talk to her about my
younger son that is recovering so
amazingly we talk about him all the time
and you know my my
you mentioned my 17 and my younger
daughter that they're probably the
easiest going about this whole thing
because they're somewhat removed from it
they weren't there right and my oldest
son can go back to college my youngest
daughter is
with family just kind of removed from
the situation playing with cousins all
the time you know she's good um
i i
have to talk to different people about
different aspects of it it feels so
bifurcated and i can talk to the
detectives about my son but i got to be
careful what i say because i want to you
know add fuel to the fire that you know
could
put them in jail longer but same time
maybe i want them in jail longer because
they tried to kill my wife and right i
feel just very torn apart in all these
different ways
and
so i just i kind of try to ignore a lot
of it you know don't try not to think
about all those disabilities but
associative pieces you know yeah
so
here's a couple things i'll give you to
walk through it and then you stop me and
ask any question anytime okay okay
so
number one
is
you gotta have
one two five nine people they're gonna
walk through this thing with you and i
want you to think of this as you're the
quarterback now for everything
and you got to have an offensive
coordinator a defensive coordinator and
a head coach somewhere who are those
people for you
rattle them off for me
oh
i mean i'm probably my best friend but
he's not in the area okay i called him
in the middle of the other night um my
cousin growing up
he's a guy that i can just call and talk
to if i ever need just to
talk about random stuff like that okay i
have a uh a neighbor that
was a um
oh shoot
i don't know him well but he was a
counselor for 20 years in the
dealing with trauma aaron
i just don't know him very well i guess
it's a weird thing you know sure i don't
know if it's a good thing though if i
don't if it's if i'm talking to someone
about this
nonsense that i don't
have a relationship with really outside
of you know friendly banter yeah
how about work
are you still having i mean obviously
you're trying to go to work every day to
pay the bills huh
i haven't been to work in a month man
okay are they taking care of you or are
you did you
i haven't made a dollar but you know
we've we put out a good find me page and
raise a little bit of money and people
have been very generous with their time
and with meals and stuff so do you have
a church community you're connected to
or absolutely okay absolutely
i've been getting a lot of input from
our lead pastor and we have a church
that
loves us and
we'll absolutely take care of we've been
there for 20 or 18 years so fantastic
cool so here's what i want you to do
when you get out a piece of paper
and i want you to come up with who your
offensive coordinator defensive
coordinator and head coach is going to
be
and you're not really going to offense i
want a defense on the other but i'm
thinking
i need somebody to help quarterback my
home help take care of this house are
there going to be meals here are the is
the light bill going to be paid
um in mo in days when i'm going to have
to be in court and someone has to help
my wife go to the bathroom whatever
those realities are going to be for you
with two people with traumatic brain
injuries
um
is there somebody you can sit down with
or two people or three people or a
couple
um like a husband a wife team or
something you can look across the table
from and say
over the next 60 days i'm gonna need you
guys to step into my life i'd like to
invite you into that
and that might be a couple at church
that you've known for a long time and
you've never been that specific but
here's the the meta here is you've got
to sit down and make your needs known
and risk asking somebody for help
okay okay
and then i want you to get whether it's
your own attorney whether it's an
attorney at church somebody you know
somebody that's gonna help you
understand the legal jargon both your
kids i'm sure got different attorneys if
they're going to try one as an adult my
guess is they is that right they got
different ones
yeah dude and at some weird moment you
nailed it you're going to have to sit by
your kids because they're minors and
they can't make decisions on their own
and you're the you're the victim right
you're on the other side of the table
and this is going to cause some major
tension in your marriage
and it's gonna you're gonna have to have
some somebody be with you at all of
these meetings if possible and that
might be your dad it might be your mom
it might be
a friend who's just like man i'm all in
on this on with you
if you don't and you that that can't
happen take a recorder with you so you
can record these meetings because what's
going to happen is you're going to start
running together on you're going to
think this one that that one and that
one i thought i was talking to this
lawyer
and uh that was actually my kid's
teacher it's gonna start jumbling up in
your head okay
okay and you were probably i would i'd
be willing to my truck's not very nice
i'd be willing to bet my truck right now
you are still in some sort of shock your
body has taken over for your brain
okay
that will slowly start to you can't do
it for long your brain your body can't
do that long term it will start to take
back it'll start to recede and those
feelings you're talking about that rage
that anger that those tears you're gonna
be sitting there playing
playing video games one night you should
start crying
that will come
it will come in heavy waves and so
having your best friend on letting them
know i'm gonna call you at crazy moments
okay please answer your phone
um and it might be i'm gonna call you
and just
let a string of expletives go that maybe
have never been put together on the face
of the earth but they're gonna come out
of my mouth and i need somebody else to
hear that because grief demands a
witness and they'll say you're good and
you'll be like yep just need to get that
out and it's 3 am and they're going to
hang up and everybody's going to go back
to sleep
or it may be
they just ask me
if my son x y and z and i know he did
that
or i know he's got a journal or i know
his passcode to his phone and the dad in
me wants to say i don't know where that
is
because i know what's on there
and the truth is i need to i need to put
that out there because he hurt somebody
he could hurt somebody again
and i need you to walk alongside with me
and make sure that i make ethical
right decisions
not emotional dad decisions
okay and have somebody that's gonna walk
so i'm just i'm those are just a few
examples
long story short you're gonna have to
have people in your life that you
assigned to a post and that will walk
through you walk through this with you
yeah okay i think i think i have a lot
of that it just feels like it's so many
different it is it is people that's why
i want you to have a head coach somebody
that will come over and this might be
your dad it might be your mom it might
be your pastor it might be an attorney
friend a church it might be anybody a
mechanic friend of church who will sit
down with you and this is number two on
a piece of paper you gotta map this
thing out you know like my buddy dave
ramsey talks about you know you gotta
make a budget here's all the debts i
have i gotta write them out and look at
them on a piece of paper that's what
you've got to do here you got too much
going on
all right go to target or go to walmart
get a a folder that you can have and put
every kid you have's name on it and your
spouse you're going to start getting
medical bills out the wazoo you're gonna
get legal stuff you're gonna have to be
here at this place and they're in that
place it's just gonna the paperwork and
the stuff and the little jargon
you're gonna have to have an
organization um your organization have
to be top-notch so start that at the
front end of this thing okay
all the paperwork's sitting in a big
pile now i know it is like i know it is
man that's what i'm telling you go get a
folder because it's gonna happen in four
months someone's gonna say hey i need
such-and-such paper what did you say
when you talked to such and such person
on this day what did you say and you
could be like dude i don't even know
what day it was that day
i want you to have a
file folder full of all the paperwork
neatly filed it's gonna help you sleep
okay i also want you to have a journal
of some sort it can be five dollars or
ten bucks that you get at walmart that
just says i talked to detective so and
so at this time on this day about this
and in six months in two years and seven
years when this stuff is still in court
or your kid comes up for parole or
whatever happens
you're going to want to look back and
say here's what this was about
all right and what i'm telling you is if
the if you've got piles of paper
everywhere and you talk to this
detective and you talk to that doctor
and this bill collector and then your
boss is like hey are you going to run a
route or what
your brain is going to go hyperactive on
you and when it goes hyperactive you're
not going to sleep at night and you
don't sleep at night you're going to
start getting really anxious you're
gonna start slipping in your own
depression and so what i want you to do
is to
keep your environment spotless
okay stay as or this may be the first
time you've ever been organized in your
life and this is this is the season
okay take a chapter for my wife on that
one because she was the organized
organized person in our family you know
what she's gonna be so proud of you
she's gonna be so proud and if you suck
at this
and this is me talking to the mirror
here
ask somebody that is a friend of yours
who's a church someone at your church
someone that's your neighbor
say i am terrible at organization i'd
really love it if someone could make it
could come by once or twice a week and
help me with this
and you will have people line up to
support you who want to help want to
love you and they don't know how and
they're great at organization but man
they're thinking this guy's dealing with
in fact he almost lost two family
members
boom they're like i can do that somebody
can help with a meal train somebody can
so that you don't have to worry about
meals for the next 30 days people want
to help but they need clarity and that's
where you can really help yourself and
then by giving people jobs and direction
okay
yeah we've gotten that output outpouring
of support with like meals and stuff but
you're right about the clarity that i've
just been trying to let it kind of
happen and that's right take a look take
ownership of it okay yeah if i ask for
something specific it usually happens
but i just don't
i don't ask enough for what exactly i or
we may need in a moment so that's the
third thing here okay we've talked about
getting people in your life we've talked
about organization
the third one is going to be grief and
you are going to have i need you to hear
me very clearly
the life that you knew is now over with
a period at the end
okay
i think i know that i know you i know
and
most people don't have the courage to
say that out loud to someone they love
and so i'm telling you as my new friend
there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and a lot of grief gets hung up because
people want to go back to life before
the affair they want to go back to the
way things were before i gained this
weight or before we had kids or before
whatever the thing is
and we spend so much time trying to get
back to the past instead of building a
new future
and so i want you because the temptation
is i can just get these kids like the
right psychologist and then we can all
get back home and get my my 10 year old
healed up and get my wife back then we
can get back to this thing and we're
just going to go back to
your life before this is now over okay
everything forward is you building
something new
and that's should be both terrifying
it is terrifying and scary
and it should also give you direction
okay
every time you think about yeah but it
used to
you can stop and go
that part's over now
now i am going to have the opportunity
to rebuild my marriage
and my wife's gonna have a lot of
healing here's what healing's gonna look
like for your wife what did i miss what
was it about me that my kids did this
how could i create kids and grow kids
that that kind of stuff is going to
unspool and unspool and you're going to
go through that too
so when i talk about you're going to get
a different wife you're going to get it
you're going to become a different
husband
it's not that your psychology is going
to be different it's that you all are
going to be asking yourselves hard
questions about what happened in our
home
and those rattle people in their core as
they should right
yeah they're difficult questions to come
face to face with for sure and they're
not going to have real good answers
no there's no answers that's going to be
satisfactory absolutely and everybody
deals with ambiguity differently or
that's just what happened differently
or maybe you're going to find a journal
or a bunch of social media stuff or a
bunch of oh my gosh i could i we missed
xy whatever the things are that come out
or
it may have just been totally random
and few things are scarier than random
right
right it'd be a lot easier if we could
point back to some abuse or to something
oh my gosh my kid just woke up and
decided to do this
i almost lost my 10 year old
um
so i want you to be hyper intentional
about every time you start to lean back
into it we just need to get back to
that part you do need to you didn't do
need to ask those questions right i mean
that is
for sure you'd be a psychopath if you
didn't answer those questions
if you're not plagued with
why and what were you doing and how and
what was it about
absolutely
absolutely you gotta ask those questions
and that brings me to the final thing
here number four okay and again i'm just
pulling this off top of my head i didn't
know where this conversation was going
to go
you my brother aaron
have to take care of aaron
and your temptation over the next six
months over the next two years is going
to be to make sure everybody else in
your world is okay
and it's gonna come at your cost
it's what i'm telling you is i want you
to never forget this
the best way you can make sure
everybody's okay is if erin's okay
and that means you may have to get
serious about your physical health for
the first time ever
is that fair
yeah that's fair yeah
you got to start lifting weights and
going on a walk
you're gonna have to be intentional
about what you eat
because when i get stressed dude there's
a special aisle in the grocery store and
it's just covered in gummy candies and
chocolate and shenanigans it's
incredible
right you got to be intentional about
what you eat you have to be attention
about going to sleep
you're gonna have to be intentional
about getting a counselor you've got a
couple of years of work ahead of you at
at least okay
yeah it's kind of a long road it is i've
been relying on my my wife to keep me in
the healthy with the eating aspect of
our relationship for
our entire marriage basically yep and
now you're in the driver's seat
there you go that's right
and it's okay to feel angry
it's okay to feel heartbroken it's okay
to
not be able to get out of bed for a
couple of days
and that's when you're gonna call on
your friends and say hey i need someone
to pick up so and so from school i can't
move today
grief is going to look different for
everybody
and you get to grieve how you need to
grieve
but you got to be intentional by taking
care of yourself okay
i think i can look to that i know you
can and i also know you're on autopilot
right now so here's the the last the
thing i want to ask you of okay okay
in two weeks
in four weeks and five weeks i want you
to call me back and we'll have you back
on and
i want you to let me know where you are
and it may be a season of man people are
healthy things are good it may be you
are in a black hole of despair and i
want you to give us a shout okay
yeah i can do that and i'm going to ask
you who's walking with you
are you being intentional about taking
care of yourself
do you have a plan of grieving this
and do you have some organization going
for you okay
okay
and last last last thing okay
your oldest and your youngest
don't lose them in this process okay no
i'm worried about them to be honest yeah
i told you earlier in this conversation
they're doing the best just because
they're kind of removed from it and i
did that somewhat intentionally and my
oldest son we had
i pulled him into it
for a week or so but after he can't go
visit his mom he can't go visit his son
because of all the covety stuff
he's not he's kind of awake to me so i
told him go back to school go back to
work you know
there's not a whole lot you can do and
he's
um
he he's doing good he's a stoic
character and my daughter she's removed
from it and she's happy-go-lucky but i'm
a little worried that that goes on too
long and they just kind of disappear
into
whatever they're going to disappear into
i've kind of lost track a little bit of
yeah of both of them you know do they
does your oldest who's in college live
around you in any shape form or fashion
well he still lives with us okay great
okay so here's the deal i mean here's
how you can do this okay every week in
your calendar this is part of your
organization you get a calendar too
i want you to plan a meal with each one
of them by yourself
okay
okay when you and this will be in the
season when you can't get out of bed
this will help you get out of bed
and in a season when
they
are so heartbroken but they're scared to
call you because they know you're
heartbroken too this will put i you'll
get to put eyes on them
so i want you to let them know from this
point you can tell them from now until
the foreseeable future
you and me are going to breakfast every
tuesday morning
build your school schedule around it
build your work skills we are not going
to miss this time together
and that's when you're going to ask
questions like how are you feeling how
are you doing how's your heart
are you angry are you pissed off are you
heartbroken all those things and you're
gonna get all that and i want you to
take your daughter out
okay
they need to see and touch dad
because everything in their world is
unanchored now
yeah and by them seeing you
you're gonna see them and you're going
to get anchored in too okay
i like that idea my my son and i my
older oldest son and i we went to church
just the two of us for the last few
weeks
um and we went out to lunch after church
two weeks in a row and we kind of gave
it up but
back on that for the next eight years
just put it in there man you got a long
road ahead of you
yeah all right aaron i'm gonna let you
go okay
thank you so much for your call brother
and we're so happy that your wife and
son are coming home that's incredible
and we will be
thinking about you guys from afar as you
go through the court process as your
family heals and as you create a new
tomorrow
keep in touch here and we'll be thinking
about you my brother